[Musique]
enfin les enfants
alors avez vous été sage aujourd'hui
ne fait pas de bruit pas trop je veux
faire une surprise à pape rhône elle est
à nicolas
je vais leur montrer ma collection de
pierres précieuses du n'est pas prudent
north pensez vous ces petits sont des
anges je leur ai promis une surprise
alors je tiens parole et bien bonne
chance hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
personne c'est exactement ce qu'il faut
pour préparer ma surprise
un salon tout sur la table
nicolas note qui ferais tu as encore
l'écart et salle haute et pas drôle de
petit moment que d'une mesure veilleux
olala
c'est déjà mieux
écoutent oui qu'as-tu bruit a coûté
ces nounours
nous
oui
qu'est-ce que c'est tout c'est
qu'ailleurs coucou c'est la surprise
d'un nounours ben dis donc un jeu près
mais c'est jean joliette je comprend une
collection de pierres précieuses de
cette importance c'est extraordinaire
attention attention vous admirez mais
vous ne touchez pas aux revenus du
porphyre de la chad 2 agathe 15 ans déjà
3e rose du cristal de la pierre ponce
jamais dans la salle de bar confrontés
les pages d'un gros c'est formidable
depuis une merveille à lahti cela c'est
précieux
ouais je trouve qu'elle appuie jali
c'est la petite mine et tu as beaucoup
c'est à sa vie non pas prône l un
superbe sa fille le pas si je vais bien
moment pour faire patronale mon chat
figure mais moi je préfère la rouge
nicolas henry viii ce n'est pas fait
pour jouer pas et ce gros caillou on
peut s'amuser avec ce troc ajout me
nicolas c'est un diamant dans cinq ans
oui quand on crache kalou dedans on
trouve un diamant la plus précieuse de
toutes les pierres
mais je veux que s'annonce tu l'auras
ton diamants non nicolas rejetant plus
médiocres où
les garnements vous va plus aux ordres
aux heureusement il est solide mais fils
un enfant il me la copierez
meschers grenard
voilà j'arrive patron il me manque
encore une assure it ou peut-être quatre
[Musique]
ans la voilà on assure it
nombre à bonnut petits brigands
[Musique]
où
oh
alors mon pauvre nounours je t'avais
prévenu ouf j'ai retrouvé toutes mes
pierre patron mais seize enfants sont
guéris bhl je n'irai plus les voir à
demain les petits allez vite vous
coucher et faute de bourran
[Musique]